the biggest national TV event grows near
every day yes the Super Bowl there are a
handful of apps that bring the NFL in
all its glory to your phone and your
first download should be the CBS sports
app CBS is hosting the game and we'll be
live streaming it via its app so if
you're without cable TV or find yourself
on the go you can tune it immediately
it's also a great option for cord
cutters grab yourself a $35 chromecast
and being the game from your phone or
tablet to your TV it's almost like the
real thing if you're in the bay area
during the Super Bowl week then you
should definitely download the NFL's
Road 250 app you can find all the
various events going on in the city and
in santa clara as well as the
opportunity to win prizes throughout the
week if you're going to the game you
absolutely need the levi's stadium app
which holds your ticket has an instant
replay feature and even lets you order
snacks and drinks from your seat but
most of us are at home so one final
necessary app pokes mate do not I repeat
do not attempt a wingstop or grocery run
on Super Bowl Sunday hit post mates and
let someone else do it for you just tip
generously please it is a holiday sort
of
you